Speaker 1: . Alex Jones, the Infowars conspiracy
theorist. You know that he is going to weigh in
on the allegedly looming arrest of the failed
former president Donald Trump. Here is Alex
Jones with some kind of emergency alerts of
some kind. Here's his. I challenge you to
understand his explanation of what's going on.
Speaker 4: This indictment of Trump will make
him the number one candidate. He's of the
candidate. This will add ten, 15 points to
him in the Republican primary polls.
Speaker 1: Okay. So first of all,
I actually don't think Jones is wrong with that.
I do think initially if Trump is arrested and it
doesn't directly interfere with his campaign,
it will help him. I don't know about 10 to 15
points. I was thinking more like 6 to 8. But
I agree with this part, at least in principle.
Speaker 4: Will absolutely shut out the audience.
You have to ask yourself if this is assured,
like Elon Musk said, to win Trump the presidency
in 2024 in a landslide, why on earth would the
system be doing it? Because they're scared.
It's the same reason the UN just indicted
Vladimir Putin for evacuating children from a war
zone, something that happens in every major war,
including in England during World War Two,
including in Russia during World War Two as well.
So within a matter of days, in
fact, it was Friday that both.
Speaker 1: Trump. Are you following this? God, I
hope someone is following this and can explain it.
Speaker 4: Got the news. He'd be indicted
and that Vladimir Putin was indicted. So
whether you love Trump or hate Trump,
whether you like Putin or hate Putin,
you have to understand this is part of the same
globalist system that is moving against leaders
they believe are not in line with their operation.
Speaker 1: Right. Globalist? Exactly.
Why do these sort of unique events I mean, listen
to the arrest of a former president if it happens.
It's never happened before. It's literally an
unprecedented event in the United States. Why
do these events trigger these wild conspiracy
theories, which, by the way, they always seem to
somehow be very Putin friendly. But that's another
part of it. When you have something happen that is
unprecedented, a rare, difficult to comprehend,
in some sense, it triggers people's assumptions
about the world and it makes them sometimes
question them. And when you have something,
the indictment of a president counts, but
something like a horrible school shooting, which
also triggered horrible conspiracy theories from
Alex Jones, when the events are complicated or
difficult to understand or horrible or whatever,
people end up uncertain and they end up confused.
And in such situations, people might look for
comfort in an alternative explanation or narrative
that is coherent and makes them feel like things
are less uncertain around them. And so one of the
things that conspiracy theories often do is
they simplify complex events. Oh, Sandy Hook,
right. We've got the interplay between gun culture
and ready access to guns. And then some people say
mental health. And then someone goes, what about
video games? And then someone says, what about
woke? And other woke was not a subject then all
this stuff. People don't want to believe. Wow,
a random, horrible event caused by all of these
different factors. It's easier for some people
to say it was a planned and staged event. That's
what this was. And that's where you get to that.
Now, here, it's all it's kind of the opposite.
Sometimes conspiracy theories take something
simple that people just don't want to believe
and they dress it up to make it more complicated.
Well, there might just be evidence Trump committed
a crime and so he would be arrested. Nope,
don't like that conclusion. So instead, it's the
International Criminal Court is coordinating the
Trump arrest with charging Putin because of some
evacuations and globalists. And then also DeSantis
and the polling and all this different stuff.
So sometimes a conspiracy theorists motive is
to simplify a truly complex event. Sometimes a
conspiracy theorist motive is to make a simple
event whose explanation you don't like much more
complicated. So people go, Wow, I don't know what
the hell is behind this? Well, maybe what's behind
that is there's evidence Trump committed a crime,
and what would be appropriate in a country
with accountability would be an arrest. Am
I convinced the arrest is coming tomorrow?
I'm not. But in the context where we believe
it is, that would be the explanation
behind what Alex Jones is doing here